in most topics you have to get pretty
advanced before you start addressing the
philosophically interesting things but
in chemistry it just starts right from
the get-go with what's arguably the most
philosophically interesting part of the
whole topic and that's the atom and the
idea of then atom is philosophers long
ago and you could look it up on the
different philosophers who first
philosophized about it they said hey you
know if I started off with I don't know
if I started off with an apple if I
started off with an apple and I just
kept cutting the Apple I only draw a
nice-looking Apple just so it doesn't
look just like a hardier there you go
have a nice looking Apple you just kept
cutting it smaller and smaller pieces so
eventually you get a piece so small so
tiny that you can't cut it anymore and
I'm sure some of these philosophers went
out there with a knife and tried to do
it and they just felt that it all if I
could just get my knife a little bit
sharper I could cut it again and again
so it was completely philosophical
construct which frankly in a lot of ways
isn't too different the ha to how the
atom is today it's really just a a a
mental abstraction that allows us to
describe a lot of observations we see in
the universe but anyway these
philosophers said well at some point we
think that there's going to be some
little point part of an Apple that they
won't be able to divide anymore and they
call that an atom it doesn't have to
just be for an Apple they said this is
true for any substance or any element
that you encounter in the universe and
so the word atom is really Greek for
uncuttable uncuttable are indivisible
uncuttable now we know that it actually
is cuttable and even though it is not a
trivial thing it's it's not the the
smallest form of matter we know we now
know that an atom is made up of other
more fundamental particles than let me
let me write them so we have the we have
the neutron and I'll draw in a second of
how they all fit together and in kind of
the structure of an atom we have a
neutron do have a proton and we have
electrons electrons
and you might already be familiar with
this if you look at the old videos about
about atomic project you'll see a
drawing that looks something like this
let me see if I can draw one so you'll
have you know something like that and
you'll have these things spinning around
that look like this
you know them orbits that look like that
and maybe something that looks like that
and the general notion behind these kind
of nuclear drawings and I'm sure they
still show up at some government defense
labs or something like that is that you
have a nucleus at the center of an atom
you have a nucleus at the center of an
atom and we know that a nucleus has
neutrons and protons neutrons and
protons and we'll talk a little bit more
about which elements have how many
neutrons and how many protons and then
orbiting orbiting and I'm going to use
the word orbit right now although we
learn in about two minutes that the word
orbit is actually the incorrect or even
the mentally incorrect way of
visualizing what electron is doing but
this the old idea was that you have
these electrons that are orbiting around
the nucleus very similar way the Earth
orbits around the Sun or the moon orbits
around the earth and it's been shown
that that's actually a very wrong way
and it there's a lot of and when we when
we cover quantum mechanics we'll learn
why this doesn't work what are kind of
the contradictions that emerge when you
try to model an electron like a planet
going around going around the Sun but
this was kind of the original idea and
frankly I think this is kind of the idea
that is is is the most mainstream way of
viewing an atom now I said an atom is
philosophically interesting why is it
philosophically interesting because the
what we now view is the accepted way of
viewing an atom really start to blur the
line between kind of you know our our
physical reality and and you know
everything in the world is just
information there really isn't any such
thing as true matter or true particles
is the way we define them in our
everyday life you know what for me a
particle it's like a grain of sand I can
pick it up touch it well you know a wave
that could be like a sound wave it could
be this you know change in energy over
time but well
especially when we do quantum mechanics
that it all gets jumbled up as we start
we'd start approaching the scales or the
size of an atom but anyway I said this
was an incorrect way of doing it what's
the correct way so it turns out I see
this is a picture not a picture really
this is also a depiction so so it's an
interesting question when I just said
you know how can you have a picture of
an atom because it actually turns out
that the wave most wavelengths of light
that we especially the visible
wavelengths of light are much larger
than the size of an atom so it's not
like something you can even you know
everything else we quote/unquote observe
in life it's by reflected light but all
of a sudden when you're dealing with an
atom reflective light is almost you
could almost view it as too big or too
blunt of an instrument with which to
observe an atom now this is a depiction
of a helium atom a helium atom a helium
atom has two protons and two neutrons or
at least this helium atom has two
protons and two neutrons and the way
they depicted here in the nucleus right
there maybe these are the two I'm
assuming there's using red for proton
and purple for Neutron Neutron seems
like purple seems like more of a neutral
color and they're sitting at the center
of this of this of this atom and then
this whole haze around there those are
the two electrons that helium has or at
least this helium atom has maybe you
could you know gain or lose an electron
but these are the two electrons you say
hey Sal that doesn't make you know how
can two electrons be this this.blur
that's kind of smeared around this this
atom and that's where it gets
philosophically interesting so you
cannot describe an electrons path around
a around a nucleus with the kind of
traditional orbit idea that we've
encountered when we look at planets or
if we just you know imagine things that
kind of a larger scale it turns out that
an electron you cannot know exactly it's
a momentum and location at any given
point in time all you can know is a
probability distribution on where it is
likely to be and the way they depicted
this black is a higher probability
you're much more likely to find the
electron here than you are here but the
electron really could be anywhere it
could even be here even though it's
completely white there but with some
very very very very very low probability
and so this function of where an
electron is this is called an orbital
orbital not to be confused with orbit
orbital orbital remember an orbit with
something like this it's like the you
know Venus going around the Sun so it's
just it's very physically easy for us to
imagine while orbital is actually a
mathematical probability function that
tells us where we're likely to find an
electron and we'll deal with a lot more
of that when we cover quantum mechanics
but that's not going to be in the scope
of this kind of introductory a set of
chemistry lectures but it's interesting
write an electron is its behavior so
bizarre at that scale that you can't I
mean to call it a particle is almost
misleading it is called a particle but
it's not a particle in the sense that
we're used to in our everyday life it's
this thing that is that you can't even
say exactly where it is it's it can be
anywhere in this haze and we'll learn
later that there are different shapes of
the Haze's as we add more and more
electrons to an atom but that to me
that's you know it starts to address
kind of philosophical issues of what
matter even is or you know do the things
we look at how real are they are how
real are they at least as we've defined
reality anyway I don't want to get too
philosophical on you but the whole
notion of electrons protons they're all
kind of predicated on this notion of
charge and we've talked about it before
when we learned about Coulomb's law and
you could you could review :
Coulomb's law as videos in the physics
playlist but the idea is that an
electron has a an electron has a
negative charge a proton sometimes
written like that has a positive charge
and a neutron has no charge and so that
was that's what was tempting about the
original model of an electron is that
they say okay if this thing has positive
charges right let's say this is two
neutrons and two protons let's say it's
the helium atom then we'll have some
positive charges here
we have some negative charges out here
opposite charges attract and so you know
if these things had some had some I
guess you could come at some velocity
they would or enough velocity they would
orbit around this it's just the way uh
just the way a planet will orbit around
the Sun but now we learn even though
this is kind of partially true that you
know the further away the further away
an electron is from the nucleus the
further away an electron is from the
nucleus it does have more I guess you
could I mean it's true potential energy
in that it will want to move towards the
nucleus but because of all of these the
the mechanics at the quantum level it
won't just do something simple like move
in a path like that like a comet would
do around the Sun it actually has a this
kind of wave-like behavior where just
has this probability function that
describes it but the kind of the further
away in orbital it does have more
potential we're gonna go a lot more into
that in future videos but anyway how do
you recognize what an element is I've
talked a lot about the philosophy and
all of that but how do I know that this
is helium is it by the number of
neutrons it has is it by the number of
protons it has is it by the number of
electrons well the answer is it's by the
number of protons so if you know the
number of protons in an element you know
what that element is and the number of
protons number of protons this is
defined as the atomic number atomic
number now so how do you is let's say I
said something has four protons four
protons how do we know what it is well
we could if we haven't memorize it we
could look it up on the periodic table
of elements which we'll be dealing with
a lot in this playlist and you'd say oh
four protons that is beryllium right
there and the atomic mass the atomic
number is the number that you see up
there and that's literally the number of
protons and that is the single-most
different that is what differentiates
one atom from another if you have 15
protons you're dealing with phosphorus
now of a sudden if you have if you have
seven
say you have 7u protons you're dealing
with nitrogen if you have eight you're
dealing with oxygen that is what defines
the element now we'll talk in the future
about what happens with with charge and
all of that but or what happens when you
gain or lose electrons but that does not
change what element you're dealing with
and likewise when you have then when you
change the number of neutrons that also
does not change the element you're
dealing with but that leads to an
obvious question of well how many
neutrons and and electrons do you have
well if a if a atom is atomically
neutral is its charge neutral that means
it has the same number of electrons and
so let's say that I have a carbon let's
say this this they say carbon it has its
atomic number of six and let's say it's
its mass number is 12 now what does this
mean so listen listen let me say further
that this isn't a this is a neutral
particle this is a neutral atom so the
atomic number for carbon is 6 that tells
us exactly how many protons it have so
if I were to draw a little model here
and this is in no way an accurate model
I would draw up 6 2 3 4 5 6 protons in
the center now and and the weight of
these protons each proton is one atomic
mass unit and we'll talk more about that
how that relates to kilograms it's a
very small fraction of kilogram roughly
one I think it's like one point six
times ten to the minus twenty seventh of
a kilogram so let's say each of these
let me write that each of these are one
atomic mass unit and that's
approximately equal to I think one point
six seven times ten to the minus 27
kilograms this is a very small number
it's actually there it's almost
impossible to to visualize at least it
is for me this tells me the the the mass
of the entire carbon atom this
particular carbon atom and this can
actually change from carbon atom to
carbon atom and this is essentially the
mass of all of the protons plus all of
the neutrons and each proton has an
atomic mass
of one in atomic mass units and each
Neutron has an atomic mass of one atomic
mass unit so this is really the number
of protons number of protons plus the
number of neutrons
number of neutrons so in this case we
have six protons so we must also have
six neutrons six neutrons plus six
protons now where are the electrons well
I said it's neutral so the the proton
has an equal positive charge as the
electrons negative charge so this is a
neutral atom and it has six protons so
it also has six electrons let me draw
that so we said it has six neutrons in
here one two three four five six so
that's its that's the nucleus right
there and then if we were to draw the
electrons well I could draw it as from
here but if we want to kind of visualize
a little better we could say okay
there's gonna be six electrons orbiting
here one two three four five six and
they're gonna be moving around in this
unpredictable way that we would have to
describe with a probability function and
so and the interesting thing about it is
most of the mass of a of a of an atom is
sitting right in here I mean you might
notice that when people care about the
mass of a when they care about kind of
the atomic mass number of a of an atom
they ignore the electrons and that's
because the mass of a proton one proton
mass wise is equal to 1836 electrons so
for thinking about the mass of an atom
for all you know for all basic purposes
you can ignore the mass of an electron
that it's really the the mass of the the
mass of the nucleus
that counts as the of the as the kind of
mass of the atom now you might see this
periodic table here and you say okay
they gave us the atomic number up there
right the atomic number of oxygen is
eight it means it has eight protons the
atomic number of silicon is 14 it has 14
protons now what is this right here
let's say listen carbon
urban they have this 12.0 107 that is
the atomic weight of carbon let me write
this right now
atomic atomic weight of carbon and the
atomic weight of carbon is 12 point OH
12 point Oh 107 now what does that mean
does that mean that you know carbon has
six protons six protons and then the
remainder the remaining six point oh 107
neutrons it has kind of this fraction of
a neutron no it means if you were to
average all of the carbon all of the
different carbon versions of carbon you
find on the planet and you were to
average the number of neutrons based on
on the different on the on the kind of
the quantity of the different types of
carbon this is the average you would get
so it turns out that carbon the two
major forms the main one you'll find is
carbon-12 so that's like this so that
has six protons and six neutrons and
then another isotope of carbon now an
isotope is the same element with a
different number of neutrons another
isotope of carbon is carbon 14 which is
much more scarce in the on the planet we
don't know how much you know in the
universe but on the planet now if you
were to average these not just a
straight-up average then you would get
you know carbon 13 and then the atomic
weight would be 13 but you weight this
one much higher because this exists in
much larger quantities on earth I mean
this is pretty much all of the carbon
that you see but there's a little bit of
this so if you weight them appropriately
the average becomes this so most of the
carbon you'll find so if you just took
found carbon in the in some place on
average its weight an atomic mass units
is going to be twelve point OH twelve
point Oh 107 but that idea of an isotope
is an interesting one remember when you
change the neutrons you're not changing
the actual fundamental element you're
just getting a different isotope a
different version of the element so
these two versions of carbon are both
isotopes now I want to leave this video
with
I think is kind of the neatest idea
behind atoms and it's kind of the most
philosophically interesting things about
them is that the relative size so you
know we have this electrons which matter
represent very little of the mass of an
atom I mean it's you know 1 mm of the
mass of an atom or and the electrons and
even then those are it's hard to even
describe them as particles because they
had you can't even tell me exactly where
and how fast one of these particles is
moving they just have a probability
function so most of the atom is sitting
that inside the nucleus and this is the
interesting thing if you look at an atom
on average if you say you know this is
my atom and let's say I had two atoms
that are bonded to each other and I
would say what you know how much of this
is actual stuff and when I say stuff
that's a very abstract concept because
we're talking about the nucleus right
because the nucleus is where all the
mass is all this stuff it turns out that
it's actually an infinitesimally small
fraction of the volume of the atom where
you know the volume of the atom it's
hard to define because the electron can
pretty much be anywhere but if you view
the volume is where you're most likely
to find the electron or you know with
90% probability you're likely to find
the electron then the nucleus is on a
lot of cases and of the way I think is
but one ten-thousandth of the volume so
if you think about when you look at
something if you look at your hand or if
you look at the wall or if you look at
your computer 99.999% of it is free
space it's nothing it's vacuum it's if
you were to just you know if you had
ultra small I guess we could call them
particles or something most of them
would pass straight through whatever you
look at so it already starts to kind of
question our holds on reality what is
there when if you know and this is this
is kind of this is fact this isn't
theory right here that if you take
anything down to the building blocks
down to the atomic level most of the
space of that kind of quote-unquote
object is free vacuum space you could go
straight through it if you could get
down to that scale I mean know this is
this image of a helium atom they say
right here this is one femtometer right
one femtometer
one femto meter did they this is the
scale of the nucleus of a helium atom
right one femtometer this is one
angstrom right and they say that equals
a hundred thousand femtometers and just
to get a sense of scale one angstrom is
1 times 10 to the negative 10 meters
right so the atom is roughly on the
scale of an angstrom in the case of
helium the nucleus is even a smaller
fraction it's 100,000 so when you if you
had you know let's say you had liquid
helium which you'd have to get very cold
to get if you're looking at that most of
it is free space if you're looking at an
iron bar the great
great-great-great-great great majority
of it is free space and we're not even
talking about what's you know maybe
there's some free space inside the
nucleus that we could talk about in the
future but to me that just blows my mind
that most things we look at are not
really solid they're really just empty
space but they look solid because of the
way light reflects on them or the forces
that repel us but there really isn't
kind of something to to touch there that
most of this right here is all free
space I think I've said the word free
space now and I think I'll leave leave
further
mind-blowing to the next video